you guys seem to have a blast making
that show I know the entire cast you've
all been here you guys seem like you
would just be goofing around the entire
time is that true that is correct sir
yeah we yeah we do it your principles
are healthy no yeah that's that's
totally true we goof off so much so that
they had to create a little like a goof
goof around room for us and we naturally
because we're 12 we call it the bone
zone sometimes I hate myself yeah but
you guys go in there and you mess your
bone zone five dudes go to the bone zone
and we play like xbox and literally grab
ass and do jokes and talk about our
lives yeah and I mean I'm sure there are
times where you know the next shot needs
to be set up and the camera the crew are
like oh that's funny Elizab it's and I'm
I'm sure there are other times where
there's like please can we just get on
with the day
yeah please can you should they give you
this room to get you out of the way
you're such children we have a picture
of you with the guys in the bone zone
yeah immeditely quintessential thing
that happened bone zone moment yeah up
and I that's that's one of the moments
where even I'm tired of it I'm just sort
of surrendering to them like look at our
water bottles our Dinks and you know
it's we are an HR nightmare yeah you
know thinking about it you really
shouldn't be a dad I'm thinking of bad
just you know just you're not ready yet
not yet not sure you've graduated from
the bone zone agreed don't tell me when
you're out of there and then you can be
a dad although I've been yeah yeah I
mean I mean what 12 year old boy
wouldn't want to talk about the bone
zone was it never mind that's gross
you
you